our next speaker is going to look I
think at this
tn bargain from a slightly different
perspective and that is in a way that
emphasis is I think a bit more of the
normalcy of it his name is Ted strife
asst he's the director of film and Media
Studies program at a Indiana University
and is recently the author of the late
age of print which came out i believe on
columbia right columbia university press
the book that very much emphasizes the
continuities rather than the
discontinuities that are so typically
attendant to the sort of pretentious
technological shifts so welcome Ted good
okay well first of all I'd like to thank
Laura and jack balkin for inviting me to
be here today and also to Perry for all
of his coordination and tech support and
all of those wonderful things you do i'd
like to thank jonathan in advance for
responding not only to the panel but of
course to the symposium thus far and ted
for his military precision in terms of
keeping us on track and making sure we
run a tight ship here and thanks to all
of you for getting up today and for
being here my talk today is in many
respects a kind of outgrowth of the book
that Ted had mentioned earlier the late
age of print everyday book culture from
consumerism to control which is a
history of at least some of the ways in
which books became the kind of prevalent
and pedestrian artifacts that we
recognize them to be today it wasn't
always the case that books were a medium
that was prevalent in everyday life and
so the question that I asked in the late
age of print is how do we get from point
A to point B but what the other sort of
aspect of the late age of print is is a
concern for some of the ways in which
with the growth of the ubiquity of books
in society there arise these incredible
anxieties about their circulation and in
response then many attempts to control
some of the ways in which books can
circulate in society so the work that
i'll be presenting here today is not
from the late age of print per se but it
is an outgrowth of some of the themes
that i introduced there particularly in
the chapter on electronic books where i
look at excuse me electronic books as a
kind of response to some of those
concerns about book circulation so
excuse me today I'll be talking about
Amazon's portable electronic ereading
device Kindle which went on sale
beginning november nineteenth 2007 and
immediately caused a stir Kindles
purpose explained amazon CEO
jeff bezos in a Newsweek cover story
would be to bring books what he called
and I love this phrase the last bastion
of analog into the digital realm later
that week on the Charlie Rose show after
having said that he decided to return
somewhat there he indicated that the
company's new ereader wasn't intended to
outlook the book by which of course he
meant to outlook the printed book quote
instead of trying to duplicate every
last feature basis clarified we have to
look for things that we can do with this
technology that we would never do with a
paper book end quote so here baseless
put his finger on what you might call
the paradox of the e-book by this i mean
that kindle and other ereading devices
are at once less and more capable of
reproducing the form and function you
might call it the experience of printed
books now i'll demonstrate more in a
moment how a great deal of public
conversation about kindle and about the
moral and intellectual worth of e-books
in general operates within the narrow
confines of this paradox but for now
what i want to do is to argue that a
fixation on Kindles paradoxically
imitative qualities the degree to which
it does or doesn't resemble the printed
book deflects attention from the ways in
which amazon aspires to transform
digital text into an economically loop
road excuse me the reading of digital
texts into an economically lucrative
value generating activity so this first
section is called of course the paradox
of the e-book now kindle presents itself
as clearly and undeniably book like by
which i mean printed book like the box
containing the first generation kindle
resembles a dictionary encyclopedia or
other substantial reference matter its
carrying case could easily pass for a
fine leather-bound journal perhaps add a
book these are what the literary
theorist Gerard genette would call the
parrot textual or perhaps it would be
more accurate in this case to say the
pair of technological elements whose
purpose is to frame the perception and
use of a given text or in the case of
Kindle a given textual platform they are
in jeanettes words the thresholds of
interpretation through which one must
pass enroute to using Kindle now this
has been ameliorated somewhat with the
introduction of the second generation
kindle if that
sort of thin thing you can see off to
the side it's actually behind the word
paper centrism but it's lying on top of
the New York Times one of the sort of
elements of kindle two point O has been
to shrink it down so that it's much
thinner than a traditional paper book
but what's also interesting to me in the
imagery that's accompanied the out roll
or the rollout excuse me of kindle two
is the way in which it is still
nevertheless put alongside consistently
paper objects this is what the literary
theorist and Technology scholar has
called Gary Hall has called paper
centrism and his wonderful book
digitized this book if you have not read
this book I cannot recommend it highly
enough and what's interesting about the
idea of paper centrism is the profound
gravitational pull that paper objects
seem to exude on digital objects and how
even when they are trying to supplant
these digital objects are trying to
supplant they're printed counterparts
they are nonetheless constantly likened
to some kind of paper original it is as
though paper is the thing so with that
then kindle has also been praised for
excuse making me go back here there we
go paper centrism okay kindle has also
been praised for mimicking the immersive
experience that to characterize printed
book reading thanks to its use of
high-tech electronic ink quote the key
figure of a printed book is that it
disappears end quote basis is claimed
and it is precisely this level of
transparency that kindle is supposed to
achieve now you can probably see where
this is headed more or less straight
into the paradox of the e-book now this
is especially so when you factor in all
of Kindles extensible improvements over
printed books which are often and widely
touted these include a thing like things
like the dictionary the ability to
change font sizes at the push of a
button the wireless connectivity and of
course the controversial text-to-speech
feature which has raised the ire of the
Authors Guild in the latest iteration of
the Kindle I sort through this paradox
of the book at length in the late age of
print so I won't try to adjudicate it or
even try to reconcile it here but I will
note however that at least since the
time of Plato virtually every
communication technology has been
accused of diminishing the presence or
the authority of the word from the human
voice to the human hand on down to the
typewriter the word processor and Beyond
so it seems like we can never win either
we resign ourselves then too
world in which technology leads in the
spouse team bargain to incrementally
diminished capacities into a spiraling
loss of authenticity or else we try to
refrain the problem so that we might ask
questions about kindle beyond its
ability or not to outlook the book and
so to do that then I want to shift gears
a little bit and to talk about this idea
of audience labor and hopefully you'll
give me a little bit of leave here this
is a moment in which my stripes as a
critical historian of media and
technology begin to present themselves
and this will get a little bit stretchy
in terms of its politics so please bear
with me dallas w Smythe who is kind of I
don't know how to describe him best in
old-school sort of political economist
of media he died in the early 1990s
wrote a path-breaking essay in 1977
called communications blind spot of
Western Marxism and it's particularly
helpful in this regard now their smiles
set out to answer the seemingly sort of
straightforward question maybe it's not
so straightforward what is the commodity
form of mass-produced advertising
supported communications now the most
immediately apparent answer is
programming content of course and in the
specific case of smiles essay writing in
1977 he was talking largely about
television but what's interesting is
that Smythe rejected the kind of
common-sense view in no uncertain terms
and this is where the Marxism comes in
bear with me quote the bourgeois
idealist view of the reality of the
communication commodity is messages
information images meaning entertainment
orientation education and manipulation
all of these concepts are subjective
mental entities and all deal with
superficial appearances end quote okay
we're done with the Marxism now now thus
media content was to use that
terminology merely the form of
appearance of something even more
fundamental the Labour audiences perhaps
unwittingly engaged in each time we
turned on our TV sets consequently
Smythe referred in his work not to
audiences but instead to the audience
product or the audience commodity he did
so in an effort to underscore the ways
in which television networks packaged
and sold viewers to advertisers with the
promise that some and hopefully many
would go on to consume the products the
latter with charged with promoting
so force my then TV watching was an
instrument of commodifying human
labor-power albeit one that put a kind
of new twist on an old Marxian theme
rather than selling one's labor power on
the open market for oneself and being
remunerated accordingly television
executives and producers essentially
alienated viewers labor from them and
reached reaped all of the financial
rewards now this is relatively old news
where Media Studies is concerned but
book historians are perhaps maybe not
quite as hip to some of these ideas so
and what remains of this paper than what
I'd like to do is to stage the problem
of Kindle by following a blueprint
similar to the one drawn up by Smythe
now this is called the labour of reading
on board mobile phone technology makes
Kindle probably the first stand-alone
ereading device to provide for
instantaneous two-way communications
between bookseller and consumer it's
little wonder then that Bezos describes
Kindle not as a device but as a service
and as an extension of the Amazon store
Kindle promises nothing less than to
usher in an era of convenient ubiquitous
bookselling much has been made about
Kindles downstream capabilities the fact
that you can access the complete
contents of any kindle formatted book in
under a minute in fact i have jonathan's
it rains book on my kindle as we speak
but what about the data transmits
upstream back to amazon.com the Kindle
license agreement in terms of use our
instruction instructive in this regard
in the sub section entitled information
received the agreement states quote the
device software will provide Amazon with
data about your device and interactions
with the service and information related
to the content of your device and your
use of it such as automatic bookmarking
of the last page read and content
deletions from the device here's the
especially intriguing part annotations
bookmarks notes highlights or similar
markings you make on your device are
backed up love those words through the
service and subject to Amazon comms
privacy notice end quote now here it's
worth mentioning all of the data you
generate while reading your kindle falls
within the purview of the information
that amazon.com collects and analyzes
for marketing purposes a return to this
point shortly but let me say a few words
first about some recent changes Amazon
is made to its corporate identity and
core mission most people probably
consider amazon.com to be an online
retail
fair enough it's only partially accurate
however since 2002 the company is
actively and until the last year or two
quite quietly been making it over into
the image of a web services provider or
even more ambitiously into a platform
upon which to conduct on and offline
businesses Kendall's data collection
efforts that's belonged to a much
broader corporate strategy in which as
Forbes magazine has put it Amazon's
quote behind the scenes data services
are beginning to emerge center stage end
quote now these include Amazon Web
Services Elastic Compute cloud or ec2
which provides pay forward on-demand
computing capabilities to third-party
businesses and Amazon simple storage
service or s3 in which businesses pay
homage amazon for the right to store
their data on the company's voluminous
servers so amazon isn't the retailer
that most of us think we know it is also
in significantly becoming what business
week is called quote a kind of 21st
century digital utility not unlike my
friend Steve of idea Nathan's old
nemesis Google now of course amazon has
been collecting analyzing and exploiting
customer information since its inception
back in 1994 but in conjunction with its
recent emphasis on data services it
seems to me that kindle promises to
intensify this process in at least three
ways first by broadening the scope of
data collection to encompass not only
the retail sphere which has long been
mine for what Oscar gandy calls
actionable customer intelligence but
also now the fine grain of everyday life
itself second and more specifically by
transforming people's idiosyncratic and
here 24 largely private reading
itineraries into data generating
activities and finally then by
implicating those acts in a larger
system of production relations whereby
they become a form of instrumental value
producing labor the result of these
processes is a version of Michel de
Soto's readily world as seen through the
looking glass readers according to certo
in the practice of everyday life
surreptitiously raid text as they
meander through them quote insinuating
the ruses of pleasure and appropriation
as they render texts temporarily
habitable end quote in this way readers
play a kind of trick on publishing
gatekeepers whose power and authority
they challenge as it were through their
small but significant acts of insert O's
words textual poaching Amazon however we
seem to be playing an even bigger trick
on Kindle readers the technology
effectively transforms the ladder into
the terminal nodes of a massively
distributed on the go focus group kindle
readers may still insinuate and
appropriate but all the while kindle is
recording mining and exploiting their
everyday textual encounters for profit
I'll end there thanks thank you very
much and can you say I don't know
penultimate but not least is Jessamine
West who is a community librarian
technologist which is a very special
very important category in the way that
for example your mechanic I think is a
very important plays a very important
role for the way that the entire United
States works she is a blogger at
Jessamine with a why com or Jessamine
comm with a why and last but certainly
not least also is very heavily involved
as a moderator of metafilter which
itself is a sort of sophisticated
aggregation service if you haven't used
it before I recommend looking at it so
without further ado again Jessamine West
thank you thanks for calling my big
community blog sophisticated I've just
got a few slides
and they're in HTML but while i wait for
this to for this to load um oh those are
the things i don't know if you saw the
little alert at the bottom that would
totally like freak people out at my
public library and make them leave and
not use the computer again for another
week or two until they'd gotten to
actually talk to me I don't know this
has nothing to do with me ok this is the
public library that I work in I would
just like to tell you that actually in
the public library we're not struggling
really badly actually where I live I
live up in Central Vermont northern New
England this is tunbridge public library
it's a we serve a population of 900 the
only reason I can support myself working
in a public library with population of
900 is because I have on those internet
jobs where I can take anywhere in the
world and I decided to go live up north
I actually live in a slightly bigger
town but this is the sort of bucolic
inside of my town and i'll be showing
you a little picture of the bucolic
outside of my library and i'm here to
talk about the small-scale individual
human issues surrounding library 2 point
0 because one of the other things that i
do when i'm not working at the public
library or moderating my sophisticated
website is i wander around i'm just
going to go back and tell them that i
wander around and talk to people in the
library world at library conferences all
over the world how to employ library to
point out how to use it in their in
their libraries something wrong okay how
to use it in their libraries what it
means and etc and one of the big things
about the library to point o thing
generally and if you want to look at the
six slides you can look at it right
there is you know how like if you've got
a friend that's sort of indicative or
representative of some small niche group
of people that maybe it's your friend in
a wheelchair or your friend with one eye
and they become the person that you ask
the questions every single question you
have ever had about well what's it like
in a wheelchair what's it like to not
have binocular vision and and your poor
hapless friend who's like well I'd
really like to be more than whatever but
I'll just answer your call
shins over and over and over again
that's um that's me and the little rural
public library like what's it like
living in the country I have a hard time
getting my head around it I went to
Vermont once and so I'm just gonna no
seriously so I'm going to talk to you
just a little bit about uh what's it
what's it like cases reclaimed for a
moment to what to respond to one concern
apparently a number of people have asked
why can't we turn off down the lights so
that you can see the slides more clearly
and unfortunately the answer is again
because someone is videotaping up there
and we end up with a sort of paradox of
the digital if we turn down the lights
yeah you won't be able to see me but you
will be able to hear you the slides will
be made available and will be I believe
swapped in for some of the videos as
well so in the later recordings of this
they will be amplified now I'll shut up
again I'm sorry thank you much for your
patience and if you happen to have like
a computer my slides are available right
now so you can go follow along right
there and there's five of them so
they'll be real short this is a picture
of my public library and it looks kind
of a lot like the other picture of the
public library you saw earlier today
except i should note you know this
picture was taken in 2008 so no
seriously this is where I work it's a
the public library so I'm going to talk
a little bit about the assumptions that
go into my work kind of on the other
side of the digital divide my library
has internet my library has wireless my
library has four computers thanks to the
gates foundation without the Gates
Foundation we would have none and if you
want to talk about a Faustian bargain
let's talk about the Gates Foundation
and their computer their computer
situation but seriously we wouldn't we
wouldn't have computers we really
wouldn't nobody would have decided that
now was really the time to do to do that
yet so the library is the only place
within 10-15 miles to get access to
public internet and as a result we are
thriving people use the library like
crazy it's open 20 22 24 hours a week
but like everybody in town has a key I
mean seriously you know that you know
that movie the village where everybody
lives in the little if you haven't seen
it I'm real sorry but I'm going to spoil
the ending for it it's there like living
in this kind of old tiny town and
there's monsters at the gates and
whatever but it turns out it's really
this
Park and they want to raise their
children in this olden time that I think
some of us hold dear to our heart as if
it were a place that actually existed
and we weren't all sick with sort of
polio and dysentery so tunbridge is
really trying to be that place and it's
wonderful i'm the luckiest person alive
to get to work at this library and then
also get to leave and talk to other
people no no and talk well sort of and
talk to other people about what it's
like because the biggest thing the
biggest thing about being a public
librarian in a library like this is the
chances that you're leaving and talking
to other librarians in big places like
this or big places like anything is
practically zero nobody leaves because
they love it there nobody leaves because
they don't get any time off nobody
leaves because they don't they can't
afford it seriously so that kind of
divide that intellectual divide is a
really big deal so a couple assumptions
that I work with and I'm just going to
kind of rattle through these um you know
dealing with that network effect that is
like the 2 point 0 thing like I don't
have internet up here on the stage and
it's actually making me a little like
nervous you know like what's my you know
might be sort of whatever that kind of
network effect requires access to
network dial-up isn't really network
most of the people in tunbridge if they
have any internet at home have dial-up
most of them bring their laptops if they
have laptops to the library to do their
software updates because you can't
actually do a software update anymore so
you want to talk let's talk about the
fact that nobody with a dial-up
connection can safely protect their
computer from whatever the big bad
internet hasn't a lot of people don't
even know there's a knowledge gap there
the Ajax ified web if I say Ajax do
people kind of know what that is that
kind of responsiveness that new websites
have we're like on google maps if you
move the map over a little bit and the
whole page doesn't have to reload from
the top down that's because Google's
loading stuff in the background while
you're looking at the page it's awesome
right if you're like me and you're kind
of in a hurry in your like you know but
that requires been with an intensity it
doesn't require require it but you know
ninety-five percent of the pages that
are designed with that kind of
responsiveness need it you know my
people don't necessarily know this so
it's one more thing on the long list of
while you're going to get online here's
some other things I should tell you
egovernment my man Obama really wants
people to get online and that's super
right let's do our taxes online let's
save some money by not mailing people
these tax forms we actually got a letter
at the tunbridge library from the IRS
saying we're not going to mail you tax
forms anymore because we're saving the
country money which is terrific right
except at the time all we had was
dial-up and so this irs.gov thing that
was supposed to solve our problems and
save you money wasn't quite as useful as
it could be right and overcoming the
digital divide requires more than just
one more website talking about the
digital divide seriously these people
are off line my cell phone does not work
at the library and so economies of scale
like the ones that you would have break
down in these edge cases where I am
here's a couple charts everybody loves
charts I read pew internet reports for
fun so let's talk about who's got
broadband half of adults in low-income
this goes down to twenty-five percent at
home half of the people between 50 and
64 have broadband at home that drops to
nineteen percent when you talk about
people over 65 which means they're also
less likely to have used the internet at
work they're less likely to have learned
it at school dial-up actually is getting
more expensive and broadband is getting
cheaper I'm in one of those little red
line neighborhoods dsl cost me 17 bucks
and people in my town are paying 20
bucks for dial-up because they don't
know there's a difference they don't
know there's something else and they're
not on the internet bargain shopping for
bandwidth and then you know let's be
serious for a second fifty percent of
the people on the face of the earth have
never made a telephone call so we're in
the rarefied air atmosphere to begin
with but that doesn't mean it's not real
and if you want to click through and
read the Pew Internet report in home
broadband I'd really recommend it when
we talk about diversity we don't have a
lot of cultural diversity in northern
New England and that makes me really sad
but what we do have is some really
aggressive class diversity the the funny
joke sort of is when you talk to people
in Vermont about their stock they'll
tell you that one of them died
it's so easy right but like we're not
having an economic crisis because we're
always in economic crisis that's nothing
new we don't have investments you know
what we want is you know internet at
home and we want our families to be sort
of safe and happy so this is who's
getting broadband rich people aren't
getting it because they have it a lot of
the people in the middle incomes get a
little bit more flush and they get some
internet and over here low income people
they're getting less internet they're
saving money by getting offline and what
does that mean for you know Obama's do
your taxes kind of thing so a couple
questions I think about these people
need egovernment the most they're
getting access to it the least and
they're only getting it through the
public library and you know federal
government's not paying me any money to
get everybody on the internet and
they're not paying me any money to teach
people how to use the internet and I'm
not complainant like I love my life but
if we really need to talk about who's
going to solve the problem because I'm
all about solving problems right how do
we figure out how to how to solve that
problem for these people um and when we
talk about I was listening to the people
earlier talk about local right why
aren't we solving these public library
problems in a national level it's crazy
well when you think about it who's who's
our national level leadership library
leadership I mean maybe you know about
the American Library Association they do
some nice legislation stuff there's some
big granting organizations that give
money but in the state of Vermont all of
our money comes from the town meeting
all of our money comes from the local
people which means you get up in a room
that's about this big with everybody
from your town and they tell you all the
things you did last year that kind of
annoyed them and then they say thank God
we're on the internet will continue to
fund you and so 2 point 0 stuff to get
back to that very briefly sometimes
feels like the anti local it feels like
it's diluting our sort of charming local
brand not in a bad way and I use it more
than anybody else but that's one of the
things that we think about it's one of
the things that I think about when
people are creating content online maybe
they're not working with their neighbors
maybe they're not getting outside that's
not a big deal but we want to make the
internet a genuine option for people
which means putting it where they are
already with connectivity but also
allowing them to interact with their
people they're interacting with
already in addition to everybody else
and somebody's got to be there first
that's like me and some other people
where we are in order to sort of move
them out there the fact that this stuff
is that free is great but it doesn't
totally solve the problem what we find
is useful showing people themselves on
the internet is the next sort of genuine
option so lastly you guys know Michael
Pollan right he talks a lot about you
know eating food and how to how to do
sort of local stuff and he's really sort
of popular where I am when we talk about
stuff like privacy one of the things
that's happening is somebody like me is
explaining to somebody like farmer bob
at my library what that really really
long contract means that they're
clicking okay to which is one of a
hundred steps to get them an email
account and being sort of in people's
way in order to explain things to them
figuring out how to set expectations for
all these things that people are using
and trying to figure out how to let them
know what's on the other side and not
freak out when they get sort of
JavaScript alerts using these tools
ourselves do we make it look
sophisticated do we make it look fun do
we make it look hard do we make it look
like a challenge and you know my patrons
are reading left to right and top to
bottom and every word you add on an
internet page is one more thing that
they have to get through so Michael
Pollan talks a lot about food and he's
like you know eat food not so much
mostly plants is his sort of summary and
my big question for my people and
relating them to your people and our
people ultimately is you know use the
internet great not too much because you
know there's other there's other sort of
things out there and and mostly mostly
what basically the internet and the
network and all that sort of stuff it
supplants and supports our lives but
it's also really important to explain to
people that it's not replacing or
overlapping the things that we already
have thanks